une semaine présentée comme la plus
importante du mandat de joe biden avant
ce jeudi soir le budget du gouvernement
doit être voté par le congrès sinon il
ya un risque de choc donne c'est à dire
une paralysie d'une partie des services
administratifs américain alors si les
républicains ont rejeté le vote du
budget c'est parce qu'il a été couplée à
une demande pour réhausser le plafond de
la dette américaine une manoeuvre assez
habituel puisqu'elle a été effectuée à
80 reprises depuis les années 60 mais
cette fois donc les républicains s'y
opposent ils disent ne pas vouloir
donner carte blanche à la politique
souhaitée par joe biden écouter nages
il n'y a aucune change aucune chance que
la conférence républicaine fasse tout
son possible pour aider les démocrates à
préserver leur temps et leur énergie
afin qu'ils puissent recommencer à faire
adopter le socialisme partisans aussi
vite que possible
achetant les démocrates vont donc devoir
trouver des arrangements pour au moins
un minima faire voter ce budget d'ici
jeudi soir mais les démocrates sont
aussi consacrées sur un autre dossier
très important il s'agit de plans
d'investissements promis par joe biden
lors de la dernière campagne
présidentielle il y a deux volets
d'abord un plan de 1000 milliards de
dollars d'investissement pour les
infrastructures sur l'ensemble du
territoire américain et puis un autre
volet de 3500 milliards de dollars cette
fois pour un certain nombre de réformes
sociales autour de la couverture santé
de l'éducation ou encore des lois pour
combattre le changement climatique alors
au sein du parti démocrate s'il ya un
blocage de la part de deux
parlementaires qu'on qualifiera plutôt
de centristes au sein du parti démocrate
eux veulent se concentrer uniquement sur
le volet infrastructures a volé plus
consensuel ils veulent reporter à plus
tard eh bien le vote sur ces réformes
sociales sauf que de l'autre côté du
parti démocrate sur l'ailé gauche du
parti on estime qu'il faut voter
simultanément les deux plans ou alors
ils ne voteront pas écoutés par exemple
bernie sanders
aucun projet de loi sur l'infrastructure
ne devrait être adopté sans un projet de
loi de réconciliation de 3500 milliards
de dollars c'est l'accord qui a été
conclu et c'est l'accord qui doit être
respecté l'infrastructure physique est
importante mais les besoins des familles
de travailleurs et la lutte contre le
changement climatique sont plus
importants les progressistes à la
chambre et au sénat sont prêts à mettre
en oeuvre l'ensemble du programme du
président biden intitulé bild bac bête
cela signifie qu'il faut investir non
seulement dont les routes et les ponts
mais aussi dans les personnes et les
communautés c'est pour toutes ces
raisons qu'il ya énormément de
tractations politiques de négociations
en coulisse donc notamment au sein du
parti démocrate joe biden c'est que le
moment est très important parce que l
année prochaine il y aura les élections
de mi-mandat et le président des états
unis pourrait potentiellement perdre la
majorité démocrate au congrès c'est la
raison pour laquelle il veut absolument
appliquer les mesures qu'il a promise
pendant la campagne présidentielle dès
maintenant et l'a d'ailleurs la preuve
de l'importance accordée à ces sujets
par le locataire de la maison blanche
c'est qu'il a annulé un déplacement
initialement prévue ce mercredi à
chicago pour parler de la vaccination à
la place il est donc resté à la maison
blanche afin de s'occuper pleinement de
ce processus législatif